Okay, the next question, I am wondering if sauna is appropriate for someone diagnosed with
Dodd Hodgkin's lymphoma, I've read different views if appropriate is there a particular brand to use. So
with lymphoma
Asada, there's different views of this. So asada with lymphoma, because asada is
is is going to it can increase swelling, right? So that's the whole idea you got heat. So with any heat you can you can increase
some swelling if you have a lymphoma at a certain site in a it can appear to get bigger and it can get irritated.
That's not with everybody. We have people maybe even on this call that have lymphoma that are used asada and felt fantastic afterwards.
It gets done to the point of why you're using a soda. The purpose of using a soda is to sweat to get to help you detox to
take pressure off of your liver and your kidneys.
And that's the purpose of the soda. I think where people get
where people have a bad experience with a soda and it's not just lymphoma patients,
it is when they try it too quickly too much for too long. So with any soda you should try it for a short period of time. You get it there for five minutes. You do five minutes until
we can tolerate that. Just fine. I did fine with that. I'm going to try to do seven minutes next time. The next day I'm going to try to do eight minutes. You gradually move up with the soda.
That's mine. That's that's what I would recommend. And you don't try to do too high of a heat. I typically recommend just 140 degrees in the soda.
What brand to use? We have people on this call that have many of them have sonas and they all have different brands of soda. Really
there's sonas that are out there that are that are
boast that they're this far infrared soda or they're this mixed infrared soda or they're a near infrared soda. And this is why it's better.
The truth is all the infrareds on us really have very little infrared at all. So don't get caught up on that aspect at all.
The purpose of the soda is not to get infrared because in truth none of the sodas have very much infrared.
Literally a five inch by six inch infrared plate costs about four thousand dollars. So when you buy a soda for a thousand dollars or $1,500
and it's because they're most boast about type of infrared. There's literally almost no infrared coming out of that plate. That's that's just not just just not true.
So don't hang out on that piece. The purpose of a soda is not to get infrared. The purpose of soda is to get heat.
The purpose of soda to heat up your body so you sweat. And the purpose of that is to take pressure off your liver and your kidneys.
So your detoxing through your skin. So your skin is an organ of detoxification, but it's only an organ of detoxification.
If you're using the sweat glands. So if you go outside in the summer and you're working in the garden and you're sweating and you are, you know, working up a really good sweat. You don't need to take a son of today. So I am a soda. I don't use it in the summer at all. So because I'm outside sweating.
So that being said, what kind of soda should you get? Well, personally, I like the sodas where that zip up and your head is exposed because of my cytos conditions. I do not like to go in a enclosed soda where I'm in it. My head gets stuffy. My cytos is get stuffy. And I get a little bit claustrophobic because of that. And I feel don't feel good in it. I want to get out after five minutes.
My soda that I zip up with my head is exposed. I feel like I can breathe. I can stay in that much longer. Again, when I start doing the soda. Again, this winter, I will start probably at five minutes. Maybe I'll tolerate 10 minutes right away. Now, they've been doing it in over a year. And, you know, use it like that. But I still only do a maximum of about 30 minutes. I think that's what I recommend personally. I only do a maximum of about 20 minutes.
So, but so those sodas that I think about those zip up sodas is there are a lot cheaper to and they heat up a lot faster.
But if you have access to one of those those wooden step together or sodas that are really, really popular and they sell at Costco and things like that and somebody's going to give you one of those issues that.
If you look on tregsness, sometimes you can find a use soda because people buy it with the greatest desires. And they use it three times and it becomes something that they hang their clothes out of they finally.
Their wife says, we got to get rid of it done thing. So, lots of times you could find them used for really cheap. So, look, that's so, but you got it. If you never tried soda, I would try it, you know, find something that has what a try one first.
Because you might hate it. And it's not just with lymphoma with some cancers. Let's say I have metastasis to the to an axillary lymph node. A soda might make it worse, like the person who asked the question before.
It might make it feel worse. It kind of feels more swollen and they don't like it. So, you have to try it. And that's why a lot of things there are mixed views on it because the truth is what works for one person doesn't work for another person.
And I bet you, if we open up the phone line, they'd be a bunch of people and say, oh, I have this and I love my son and other people's and I don't like soda. I just don't do it. So, everybody's different. So, you got to just give it a shot.
And as far as low EFF unit, I don't know. I tested R1 that we have on our store. And for EFFs, it is very low EFF. I don't know. I haven't tested the other ones on the market.
So, we do sell the zip up one. And it's just drop ship from the manufacturer.
And if you do want it from us, you have to, we used to sell it for 10% off because I just want to sell it at cost. But then the company that we buy it from, called us, actually, this is about six months ago or so.
Paul said, we can't sell it for cheaper. This is, you know, it's going to get sold in people and sell it. So, if you do buy it for us, call us and we'll give you a 10% off of the
solder. We just can't put it on the store in their place.